I was there on a Wednesday and the
lineup in order when asan Hamad Brian
Simpson Jim Brewer Tony Hinchcliffe and
Joe Rogan to close it out the best part
about attending the Joe Rogan and
friends show is that you have no idea
who the friends are going to be heading
into the show so each comic that gets
called up is a complete surprise the
anticipation before each intro is
palpable in the room everyone is on the
edge of their seats to see if their
favorite comedian is about to walk on
stage like the very next night after I
was at the mothership Joey Diaz
surprised the audience completely
unannounced
foreign
[Applause]